Whoa, it's an elephant.
I think it's a baby elephant.
You know what we should do? Let's take a photo and send it to my sister, Katie.
She is also a junior ranger.
Hold still young one.
Hi Katie, so did you find anything about the baby elephant?
Hi Leo, the elephant you found is an Asian elephant.
The largest land animal in Asia.
Though they are smaller than the African elephant.
Asian elephants can grow up to three meters tall.
Wow, that's so big.
Elephants have long noses called trunks.
They use their trunks like we use our hands.
With their trunks they can greet each other like a handshake...
...and pick up objects as heavy as a tree.
As heavy as a tree?
Wow, elephant trunks sure are strong.
Earlier we saw the baby elephant grab some grass with its trunk.
That's because they need to eat a lot of food.
They eat all kinds of grasses, small plants, bushes, fruit, twigs, tree bark, and roots.
Where do Asian elephants live?
The Asian elephant can be found in lowland forests...
...and grasslands of India, China and Southeast Asia.
Baby elephant must be hungry.
We should bring it back to its mother.
Come and join us.